I mean I actually have five patents
where you can actually be with somebody
and embrace them and be feel like you're
with them in three-dimensional space
right I'm not having a computer hug me I
don't know what you're hooking up your
sleeve there but no I'm not getting warm
and cozy with arms sticking out of my
laptop
[Music]
this is StarTalk I'm your host Neil
deGrasse Tyson your personal
astrophysicist and today we're gonna
tackle a subject that's on everybody's
mind at some point in their life and for
some people it's on their minds all the
time and it has to do with longevity
your health longevity and especially
immortality and what any of that has to
do with technology
and the pace that technology has been
unfolding not only you know over the
past Century but especially over the
past decades and there's one person who
comes to mind as a world expert on this
who's probably done more thinking on
these topics than anyone else ever born
possibly not whoever will be born but
certainly up until this moment and
there's none other than Ray Kurzweil Ray
welcome to StarTalk yeah great to be
here great to see you again yes thank
you this is this is not our first rodeo
together I've interviewed you before you
you've gotten into such fascinating
research topics throughout your life
um you're an author you're an inventor
you're a futurist and you have a an
uncannonly
accurate track record for making
predictions even predictions like we
don't want to be true but they are and
you know this right so that makes it
kind of awkward having conversations
with you about this you're also the
co-founder of the singularity group
that's a topic we'll get into a little
later but that some of that derives from
you you had a book back in 2005 the
singularity is near and you haven't
stopped thinking about it since uh and
so
tell me why do you think we'll one day
live forever
well I can't go on your show and say
I've done it I've lived forever you're
actually a thousand years old right but
we're going to achieve something called
Longevity escape velocity
so I mean right now when you go forward
a year you don't you lose part of that
gear we pick up uh technologies that
will extend us but not not a full year
so we're actually losing time uh
progress is exponential keeps getting
faster and we'll get to a point where
we'll make so much progress and when you
go forward a year your longevity will go
forward a year or even more
and if you're actually in touch with the
technology I believe we'll get there by
2029.
so on October 12th 20 at 9 00 A.M
that's awfully specific dude December
31st
but just to be just to clarify so we're
on the same page so uh the year I was
born there's a certain life expectancy
that the medical community would have
for me the year I was born and the year
I die over the over those decades
medicines and Technologies and
understandings have improved so that I'm
living longer than they previously had
predicted for me
and the progress is exponential so we'll
get to a point where the progress is so
fast that it will keep up with time
going by so when the year goes by your
longevity will actually improve by a
year or even more than a year
particularly if you're in touch with the
technology and I love the phrase escape
velocity so at that point everyone born
at that point onward will basically live
forever this is what you're saying
well not necessarily let's say you're a
10 year old and they calculate your
longevity is many many decades you could
die you know the next day so well
natural dying a natural death of course
we're not talking about you know
drowning or falling off a ladder right
so
well things are somewhat unpredictable
so even if you have a longevity that's
goes out it's not a guarantee
but we will actually be able to
as we go further out we'll actually be
able to register what our brains are
doing
uh because we're going to actually merge
with technology and that's going to keep
track of what we're thinking
uh and anything that's digital is backed
up
so ultimately we'll be able to recreate
ourselves
well let's get to that in a minute wait
wait hold put a pin in that just for a
quick second if
the day we reach escape velocity would
we have done so purely by advances in
medicines and human physiology
well there are different stages when we
get out to the
2040s
uh everything that we're thinking will
be backed up
and that's not so amazing I mean this is
backed up if I lose if I throw this into
the the river and it washes away I can
recreate it because it's all backed up
when we haven't backed up our brains But
ultimately we'll do that because we're
gonna that's a whole story but we'll be
able to back up uh what we're thinking
and really recreate ourselves but is
that that's not what you mean when you
talk about adding a year per year is it
that's a different story that's actually
understanding our
our uh
organs and so no I get that so I just
want to just put that to uh I'll give
you an example this just happened I've
had diabetes for 40 years I've kept it
uh controlled uh I have this thing here
which actually measures my glucose
gonna get another one slightly bigger
but actually very small that actually
has insulin and can uh put it into my
bloodstream so it's basically an
artificial pancreas
so if I suddenly eat a lot of sugar
it'll detect that and then release more
insulin I haven't eaten anything for a
while it won't release insulin it'll be
just like your pancreas so it's a
pancreas patch that's crazy yeah okay
but it's actually replacing your organs
now we could do that with all of your
organs and ultimately we'll be able to
do that and these things are very
reliable
uh and much much safer than your real
organs
so when we get to the 2030s we'll be
actually supplementing our organs and
redoing them
yeah but that's a different thing
from the biomedical Community saying we
have a cure for diabetes so I don't you
don't need to replace your pancreas with
a patch your pancreas works perfectly or
any other failure of your organs if we
get into the genome and know what's what
the failure mode is I mean there's
different ways of overcoming problems
with your organs I mean one is to
replace it and others to fix it
uh fixing your organs is not perfect
either
but we'll actually have a way of
overcoming different issues that we have
with our body because our bodies are
definitely not perfect and actually we
can do a better job than your real
pancreas with this artificial pancakes
so anyway that's just an example of
being able to
basically overcome problems with your
organs
all right so we start swapping it out
and we upload your brain so now there's
like a box on the table all right that's
your brain well well uploading your
brain is a little bit later
um but yes we'll be able to I mean what
we're going to first do
is connect our uh
parts of our brain where we do our
thinking
to the cloud
uh just the way this does I mean you can
actually use this without being
connected to the cloud the pack but you
mean the your smartphone yes my
smartphone
but it's pretty useless
because it doesn't know very much so for
this to really be effective it has to
connect to the cloud but our brain is
not connected to the cloud
so that's going to happen
in the 2030s
and
we will then
be able to
I mean this really amplifies our brain
but I have to have it if I put it down
and I don't have it handy I can't use it
yeah but right I'm not giving you a
scalpel to go into my brain and put
electrodes if I have just as good access
to the cloud by holding a smartphone and
touching it with my thumbs
well uh I mean that is a point but
should go in with a scalpel I mean we'll
we'll send uh Nanobots through the
bloodstream oh I feel much better about
that now
well
I mean if I were to describe how
everybody has this phone and it actually
amplifies our mind
20 years ago people in fact which I did
do and people thought that was crazy
and now everybody has this everybody's
got a speech and 500 people there and I
said who does not have their smartphone
handy and nobody raised their hand right
like everybody has this that wasn't true
five years ago and definitely wasn't
true 10 years ago
so people get used to things it's much
better to actually have it in your brain
you have it instantly uh trying to reach
your phone typing on it is awkward
uh this will be much better so you'd be
carrying Wi-Fi antennas inside your head
somehow right uh I mean we'll make that
more reliable than it is now
okay
so how about so what happens if you're
walking around and then you hit a what
do you call a dead zone a dead zone what
happens is your brain shut off how does
that play out
well I mean that's something we're going
to have to overcome
uh I mean we're talking about the 2030s
and 2040s so
so tell me about these Nanobots that
you're describing if whether we broadly
think of that as sort of nano technology
uh what what is the anatomy of a nanobot
in the service of your visions
well it just goes into the to your uh
neocortex
and it can actually pick up what the
near what each
neocortex module is doing
and connected to the cloud and get
feedback from the cloud and it basically
I mean it's just like your phone
it basically amplifies what you're doing
in your brain yeah but it's one thing to
say that technology advances and that's
a very different thing to say that our
understanding of our own brain
has advanced I mean that's going to
happen much more slowly yes we can
understand our brain but it's very
limited
um
and ultimately we want to expand our
brain I mean we have a large head
so that we can actually think a lot
but it's limited
and even if you're Superior in one field
like Einstein was brilliant in physics
and he actually was interested in
playing the violin but he was no Yasha
Heifetz Yasha Heifetz was Master of the
violin he was interested in physics but
he was no Einstein okay we have a
limited capacity in our brains so
ultimately we'd like to amplify that and
actually multiply it by two by ten by a
thousand ultimately by a million but it
requires you know enough about what your
brain is doing to know what it is that
you need to amplify amplify and right
now it's
electrochemical
synaptic signals right I mean that we
don't we it's hard for us to really make
sense of
I don't see that progressing at the rate
that your machines are I guess that's my
point so the machine is going to help us
we got to know enough about the brain so
that your nanobot can insert in the
right place I mean I can show you this
price performance of computation that
just uh it started 80 years ago and
every year we have more and more of it
oh by the way I was I was honored for
you to have shared with me the
manuscript of your next book for a book
not coming out until 2023 uh and with
you had an audacious title for it the
the singularity is is is nearer is is he
what did you title it
That's right The Singularity is nearer
it's near okay because he says near was
the imprisonment now it's nearer so
you're just you're you're all in on this
but I remember you had a fascinating set
of charts in there tell me about this
first one which to me was the most
mind-blowing of them all
well this shows the amount of
computation uh you can get per dollar
uh and it increases every single year
and it looks like one person was in
charge of this but actually this is just
uh the progress that we've made in
computation
uh with nobody being in charge of it
started with Azusa one in nineteen
41. he was a German he showed it to the
Nazi government uh they they felt the
computation was not important and did
not support him the second one is Isuzu
II the third one was Colossus which was
done by Alan Turing in England uh and
they got very much behind that including
the United States and they cracked the
German Enigma code and enabled Britain
to win that war despite the fact that
they were outnumbered uh gave us a
launching pad for our D-Day invasion a
fascinating film based on that story too
yes so there's lots of different stories
at all of these points but we started
out at
.0007 calculations per second per dollar
and the last one we have 50 000
calculations uh per second per dollar
uh so it has grown exponentially and
it's and it keeps going people used to
call this Moore's law but I mean there's
80 dots on this only 10 of them are
Intel
and people constantly come and say
Moore's law has ended I mean I remember
right before the pandemic people saying
oh Muslim has ended
um but that's not the case and I never
believed that and it's continuing today
uh so this provides more and more
computation for the same cost
uh uh each year but that doesn't mean we
know our brain better why should it mean
that I mean we you know we are a moral
enough civilization that we don't line
people up and cut open their heads and
do experiments on it right so a lot of
what you're predicting is predicated on
the machine brain interface no I mean
it's really uh
capturing what each neocortex is doing
and we understand enough about that
today
passing it onto the cloud which will
basically provide the same kind of
things outside the brain
I mean we're doing for example large
language models which is just in a
computer
and you can actually talk to it and it
will actually talk back to you and it's
not just giving you samples of what
humans have have written it's actually
capturing
uh understanding of language so we we
understand a lot of what about what
humans are doing
so maybe it's just additive to your
brain rather than infused within your
own synapses right if it's just an
add-on that that works perhaps
that that is the idea it's basically to
add to it I mean our
computers already understand a lot about
what we're doing
but we don't have a very good interface
so this is one way of interfacing it and
so okay so this involves sort of
nanotech Nanobots and I want to chat a
little bit more about that after the
break but also uh you know that the 900
pound gorilla in the room here is the
day that the computing power equals or
exceeds anything humans can do not just
how well you play the game of chess or
the game of Go but it can outperform Us
in everything we had previously held as
distinctly human I mean Turing created
this test the Turing test in 1950
uh
uh and we haven't managed to pass it yet
but in 1999 when I wrote The Age of
spiritual machines
I predicted that we would pass the
Turing test by 2029 so in 30 years
and Stanford was so alarmed at this they
created a worldwide conference and
people came from all over the world AI
experts and we did the first poll
and people felt that yes we would pass
the Turing test which would mean that a
computer could do everything that a
human could do
uh by but they said it would take a
hundred years
so so the AI experts were saying 100
years I was saying 30 years
there's been so much progress in AI
recently
a year ago they were saying 2042 I was
still saying 2029
three months ago they were saying 2030
so basically they're green
and you're quietly watching them
one by one drop like fly jumping into
your into your boat that's what you're
watching here that's that's hilarious so
that's gonna happen by the end of this
decade
uh and AI experts now agree with me on
this
and when we get to the 2030s we will
amplify our own brain by connecting to
it but the computer already understands
everything that a human can do
and it actually goes Way Beyond him so I
mean to pass the tearing test you would
actually have to dumb itself down
because if it showed its capability
that goes Way Beyond what a human can do
uh people wouldn't would know it's a
machine
so it it's so good it comes out the
other side of the Turing test uh wow
it's not like it can't keep up with us
is that it's so far ahead of us no human
can do everything that computers have
learned
like take go for example because way
past what a human can do so Lisa doll
who's the best human ago in the world
said he's not going to play go anymore
because machines are so much better than
him there's really no point in doing it
um
but no I just I'm just it's hilarious
that the Turing test can be turned
upside down where you say don't be too
smart because then they'll know you're a
computer
well that that's a major issue in
passing a Turing test when we come back
we'll continue my conversation with
futurist Ray Kurzweil on Star Talk
we're back start talk got a one-on-one
special interview with futurist Ray
Kurzweil this might be our third time in
conversation over the past 10 years and
this guy's he's true to his word he
makes a prediction about Computing about
Society about our culture and it's scary
how how on top of this this man really
is and we've got him right here on this
show uh so Ray it in your your book The
The Singularity is nearer coming out in
2023 uh you're you're doubling down on
so much of your earlier predictions
you're saying yep uh maybe it's
happening even sooner than I'd predicted
no it's happening on schedule but uh
it's actually less alarming when I wrote
this in 2005 things we just assumed
today
our reality
people didn't assume that then so the
whole thing was very surprising in 2005
today we assume that and I mean people
are greatly Amplified by the machines
that we carry around right there was no
smartphone in 2005 right right yeah and
nobody goes outside without it I mean if
if I actually leave and I've noticed I
don't have my cell phone it's like I've
lost three quarters of my brain I've got
to go back and get it
for some people it's 90 of their brain
they're playing
so Ray what what is it with humans that
we can't think exponentially about the
world and and even if we when presented
with our own awareness our own awareness
even gets it wrong uh in the manuscript
you were kind enough to share with me of
your upcoming book there are all these
charts that it's almost makes you
embarrassed to be human that people
think this way uh one of them was on uh
how how much of the world people think
live in poverty tell me about that one
well there was actually a poll 23 000
people in 24 countries and they were
asked over the last 20 years uh what has
happened with poverty in the world
and have more people become impoverished
or less people
70 thought it had gotten worse
88 thought it had gotten worse and
stayed the same
in fact it had fallen by 50 percent
uh and only one percent thought that was
true and people think that things are
getting worse
and and people are not having children
because they think that the world is
getting worse where in fact it's getting
better I mean I measure all these
different
uh attributes of of how we how you
measure that you must add 100 charts in
this book I mean I
it was like well every every next
chart's like damn damn what is
everything
it was a it was like
so it's it's almost embarrassing I have
to say
and things are getting better but we
tend to forget that
uh in fact there's a common human
attribute where we tend to remember
positive things from the past
but we wouldn't want to go back even to
1900 the human life expectancy was 48.
it was 30 in in 1800
and we had very few abilities to deal
with disease and so on
uh so things are getting better
but we forget that and all we see in the
news is is the bad news the bad news is
true but
this good news that we don't attribute
because the good news happens like every
day the facts hidden in plain sight that
life is getting better for people that
bodes well for living forever right if
we were in the middle of poverty and
disaster and War you're not going to
want to live forever under those
conditions so maybe not I mean that's a
deeply philosophical issue sure but they
both they feed into each other the fact
that things are getting not alive you
can't
improve anything you can't
enjoy the world I mean
if you have any joy in your life you
want to continue to live do I get that
but I'm saying so but these two forces
are resonant the fact that everything is
getting better statistically for more
people than ever before and we're
developing the power to live forever so
but that would have consequences all
right social cultural political
consequences
all right uh you know the the supply
chain of food the the resources of Earth
to sustain such a population
so to extol the value or virtue of
living forever but not see what
challenges that would bring that would
be irresponsible uh if you had a linear
mindset okay dig me out of this one
well uh
I mean take renewable resources for
energy
uh that's growing exponentially
and we'll actually be making more uh
energy from things like solar I mean you
look at the graph you can see where it's
going
same thing with food I mean we can
actually produce food very inexpensively
you know once we get uh
some technologies that we're working on
to work but would you would you live
forever if you had the choice
I would like to live to tomorrow
okay
okay and and I'm okay it's a low bar
that's a low bar but okay we'll give it
to you let's give it let's give it to
Ray all right I think tomorrow I'm going
to want to live to the next day
and I and
people want to continue to live
people sometimes talk oh I want to live
another 20 years 40 years whatever
um
but
they definitely want to live to tomorrow
and in 40 years from now they want to
live to tomorrow I mean I had an ounce
it was 98 she died
recently but I talked to her a couple
months before she died
she was a very vibrant woman she has a
psychologist she actually talked to her
patients at 98.
um
and I was actually talking to her about
longevity Escape philosophy
and explaining that and she said and she
said well do we have it now and I said
well I think we'll have it by 2029
and she said could could you work on
that to make it that a little faster
because she won't people want to
continue to live she wants to see
tomorrow
and
you know people uh get some pleasure
from life and they want to continue to
live and they also want to continue to
create you know further Technologies for
tomorrow
this reminds me of the Frank Sinatra
quote it's been attributed to him at
least is that live every day like it's
your last because
one day it that'll be true that is your
last day
well people have assumed that and
certainly that's been true
uh so we're actually going to be able to
overcome that but people uh want to
continue unless they're
under unbearable pain either physically
emotionally or spiritually and then they
don't want to go on right right but
otherwise people do want to go and those
are exceptions of clearly and important
exceptions right but they're exceptions
correct well we're also working on
alleviating those these kinds of
problems uh before we go to break let me
just ask there there's a Next Generation
that
doesn't see a good world that we're
leaving for them they see the the the
vagaries of climate change they they see
regressive thinking on the social
cultural front right but they're really
not aware of what's happening and I've I
mean I've had many debates with
particularly younger people that have
this View
[Music]
um
they're not aware of how close we are
for example to replacing everything with
renewable energy
uh and many other of the graphs that I
show they're just not aware of it and I
think things are getting worse when
they're actually getting better
uh
uh and you know we could go through all
these graphs but it definitely shows
that
things are getting better
and people are unaware of it they've
been deluded by the forces of media by
whatever else is not looking at those
same graphs
because it sells news stories I mean the
progress in this is not news it's like
every day we're making progress
and it's kind of the same story
but if you've over over a certain amount
of time you see they would make rapid
progress right so one of them the you
might have the number on the tip of your
tongue it was the percent by which
poverty drops in the world each day
I thought that was a great number it was
like
.001 or something like that yeah and
it's like and it's almost an ignorable
amount until you take a step back and
look at the sum over the years and over
the decades exactly so that's not news
in fact news it's all negative because
that's what gets attention
and a lot of the news it's true
I mean I'm not saying there's no bad
news in the world
uh but that's all we're exposed to so
what of our problems today
might not be tractable by this sort of
Eternal Moore's Law that's unfolding in
front of us
I'm not aware of something that we can't
that we're not making progress on how
about transportation
you mentioned that in your book
the transportation you know we we uh
planes today are going the same speed
they went 50 years ago you know we're
not getting to Tokyo faster than we did
in the yeah one thing we don't really
need to travel that much I mean because
technology creates a zoom call and you
don't have to go okay so I'm there at
the speed of light okay that's and Jim
calls won't just be a picture we'll be
able to actually embrace each other I
mean I actually have five patents where
you can use technology today where you
can actually be with somebody and and
embrace them and be feel like you're
with them in three-dimensional space so
right I'm not having a computer hug me I
don't know what you're hooking up your
sleeve there but no I'm not getting warm
and cozy with arms sticking out of my
laptop all right so what do you what are
you cooking up here
uh
I mean it's something where you can
actually be with somebody in a
three-dimensional space even if you're a
part okay but you can't physically but
there's many different ways of doing
that there's like a holographic thing I
guess
right yeah well I mean uh Holograms are
3DS yeah okay okay
I I there was a I think I saw a sci-fi
movie where you saw the person who you
needed it to be but that person was
played by another person who had
approximately the same body shape and
body type but while you were so you that
person got paid to play this role but
you interacting with that person saw and
felt and communicated with the person
who you intended it to be yeah I did
actually see that movie uh so that's I
mean one approach but I mean there's
many different ways in which we'll bring
3d to
to Virtual Reality into
Zoom calls and you made a very important
point in in your book The Singularity is
nearer something that I only mildly
appreciated but after reading it I I was
all in in the in the ray Camp it's that
people have the urge to think of
progress not only linearly of course but
also progress in only one
sector oh the chips are getting Faster
by this amount each time and that's what
really matters let's track the chips but
you make a very convincing case that
it's a much broader phenomenon than that
right that's a very good point I mean
this graph that we talked about of the
price performance of computation is not
everything comes from that that's just
one example of how technology advances
over time everything progresses that way
and you can point to different types of
technology and how they progress every
year and and the people inventing the
faster chips or not thinking that one
day Movie Makers are going to fully
exploit the power of computing to tell
stories in movies I'm sure that was not
on anybody's thought in the 1960s when
they were working hard on the IBM 360 or
whatever else was coming online at the
time
would you agree with that yeah I mean
before 1900 we didn't have movies at all
okay
that's not that long ago no it's not no
no it's not it's not uh well let's take
a quick break when we come back I want
to get all in on
your feelings about AI because that's a
very controversial subject as you know
and I just are you an optimist in that
because most AI experts are quite
pessimistic and if not them then it's
every movie ever made about AI would
scare The Living Daylights out of you
and they you'd want to stop every active
AI being conducted in every lab in the
world I want to get your candid views on
that when we come back with my
conversation with Ray Kurzweil on Star
Talk
we're back Star Talk a special
one-on-one conversation I'm having with
the one and only Ray Kurzweil futurist
extraordinaire and he's not just
somebody who sits home in his armchair
and says gee I wonder wouldn't it be
cool if we had flying cars no Ray uh
thinks about
agencies he thinks about Industries he
thinks about
Innovation he tracks what's been
happening in the past looks at those
Trends lines trend lines it applies his
own Ingenuity to it his own creativity
and he's telling us what is in store
yeah well I mean actually got into
futurism because of my interest in being
an inventor
so it wasn't just futurism to think
about what the future will be like but
to really time my own inventions because
certain inventions don't make sense at
particular periods of time and so I use
futurism
to tell when we should actually be doing
certain things excellent plus I I'm I
admire the fact that you slap dates on
when you think things will happen and
that's that's bold that's that's that's
some as they say that you got gonads if
you can understand because there's
nothing more embarrassing than a wrong
prediction that people make even if it
doesn't land in a time period right
there's just certain things that never
came true that people either dreamed up
or wished would be true but so let's
let's get into this AI thing
um I my personal
view here is computers and machines
think of them as one one force operating
on civilization uh it wasn't the end of
the world when we had machines replace
oxen or otherwise human labor on a farm
right I mean it's just we had tractors
now that does it and I mean we had we
had 80 percent
uh in 1800 80 of the workforce worked on
producing food so basically if you if
you were working you were producing food
at least 80 percent today that's two
percent
so that we're producing more food on
less land with fewer people than ever
before yeah eighty percent to two
percent yeah in fact you can go your
whole life if you grew up in a city and
never even meet a farmer right and I
think that of our founding fathers how
many of them were farmers it was like
half or so there's some interesting
former Revolution uh the American
Revolution was was a revolution of
farmers
and yet people found other jobs so we we
survive an era where our physical labor
and that of our our pack animals is
replaced by machines and it wasn't the
end of civilization and yes people found
other jobs other Industries rose up in
spite of whatever fears they might have
had at the time I mean if our oppression
futurist in 1900 I would say that all of
your jobs are going away
and people go oh my God how are we going
to make money and let's say well you're
going to become an I.T engineer and do
quantum physics and no one would have
any idea what I'm even talking about
so but they wouldn't even go but beyond
that they wouldn't even allow you to say
instead of being a uh instead of being a
a blacksmith for horses you'll fix
engines on cars
they probably could not imagine an
industry that rose up surrounding I
couldn't imagine any of the jobs that
came but we actually have a higher
fraction of people working today than we
did before it's actually been increasing
and the amount of money you've made in
constant dollars has greatly Advanced
that's another graph I have here it's uh
it has gone up substantially here's a
graph you'd haven't put together how
many 20 something millionaire YouTubers
there are foreign
that didn't even exist 15 years ago
whenever it came into so that's
something a good example of the kinds of
new jobs that we have
uh and as as intelligence increases
we're going to be doing more and more
intelligent things uh we're going to
become much smarter in the future and we
would not want to go back to
you know primitive past of today the
idiot days of the 2022 wait wait but but
right at if AI starts taking all the
jobs not just the old jobs but any new
job that people can come up with AI is
going to do it doesn't that we have to
now think a geopolitically about the
impact of this
right so there's two ways of looking at
this as humans
and those AIS the AIS are going to go
way past what humans can do and so what
are humans going to be able to do
but that's really not the way I look at
it
we we create technology to advance
ourselves
I mean the technology is not some Alien
Invasion From Mars I mean we created to
overcome limitations that we have our
own problems with our organs we have
problems with everything and we come up
with technology that moves us past it
and we bring this into ourselves so
that's why I'm talking about advancing
in our own brains and capabilities with
technology in the future
so we're going to bring the AI into
ourselves and we're going to become
smarter and we're going to be able to do
our jobs because it's going to be us and
AI together
not AI is a separate disembodied force
that as every movie has decided uh that
the AI will judge that we are a Scourge
on the Earth
the AI is not coming from ours I mean we
we're creating it so it's a overcome
problems that we have
yeah but this this fear of achieving
Consciousness I mean AI
undermines everything we do I mean every
single Financial I love it I love AI
don't get me wrong here but I'm saying
what happens
if you know the Fear Factor I guess is a
singularity of its own perhaps is if AI
quote achieves Consciousness it makes
decisions all by itself
well let's get back to Consciousness at
a moment but I mean this has been an
issue ever since the Luddite
uh occurred in the early in the 1800s
um
they saw machines are being built and
more machines are being built and every
week they're announcing some new
machines and employment's going to be uh
won't exist but in fact employment went
up not down and continues today to go up
in that town uh that's because we use
the technology to make ourselves more
capable
so it's interesting I remember reading I
read a lot of history I I enjoy looking
at how people used to think about their
own time one of them was uh oh at the
rate machines are are replacing human
work one day we will only need a
three-day work week
and what what what Enchanted Me by that
is it's the assumption that the work
people were doing in that day was the
only work that would ever be done
and so you have machines doing it now
there's less work total work to do in
the world without anyone thinking that
maybe you're freed up to think of other
things invent new uh projects new ideas
new challenges that's exactly exactly
the case and particularly when we
increase our own intelligence we're
going to think of all kinds of things we
can't even imagine today
So when you say intelligence could you
be could you be more specific about that
because or in fact before we even get
there could you remind us
what the parts of the brain are doing
for us
and because we we hear joke about The
Reptilian Brain or the you know and what
part of the brain makes us us rather
than some other Apes could you just
spend a moment telling us about that
well there are parts of the brain that
control our breathing and so on that are
not that important
uh this well how much you want to
breathe you mean they're not important
for intelligence yeah
cerebellum is where we do our ability to
put different things together
and so you have lots of different
constraints and our cerebellum can solve
some of those problems
uh We've greatly Amplified that with our
machines which can actually go beyond
what a normal human brain can do
and ultimately we'll connect our
cerebellum
to the cloud which basically will just
amp uh
expanded beyond what our brain can do I
mean the reason we have such a large
head is to accommodate a certain amount
of cerebellum
now there's actually one other thing
that we need because there are other
animals that have a brain that are as
big as us or even larger like an
elephant or whale actually have a larger
brain they don't have a thumb
I mean this thing is actually very key
well they have a opposable thumb they
have thumb bones right because they're
mammals but right
they don't have an opposable thumb right
so I can think and look at a tree and go
well I could take that branch and strip
off the leaves and create a tool uh they
can't do that they might imagine it but
they can't don't have a proposable thumb
to to create that so our whole
technology was enabled by our opposable
thumb
okay but then also are you suggesting
that's an important Point AI we think of
it as a computer-based
thing phenomenon but can can AI
create a sculpt a sculpture you know I
do that with my hands does AI do that
you have to create a robot that jumps
out of the machine and to do that right
well since we have the ability to create
technology we can create robots and the
robots have an opposable thumb okay okay
okay so uh getting back to that point
isn't there a day where there is nothing
left for humans to do
and then there's a world where AI does
everything better than we can and so how
do we
uh is there is that the end of is that
the end of the economy
that would be the end the end of us if
we can't expand Who We Are but if we can
actually put AI into ourselves which
you've already done with things like
cell phones and so on but if we can
actually amplify our ability to think
uh then we become the AI we can compete
with ourselves because we are the AI and
that's why we created AI is to expand
our ability to think uh you said this
the last time we were in conversation
and I've never forgotten it and I've
repeated it a hundred times so I want
people to hear it from you firsthand uh
your rebuttal to the comment you know
the first AI only rich people are going
to have it and then uh they're going to
take over the world and there'll be more
of the have-nots versus The Haves and
this is going to create an imbalanced
world
right so if you go back 20 years you
have to be actually pretty wealthy to
have one of these new cell phones that
came out because they were very
expensive and only wealthy people could
afford them and they didn't do very much
uh so
uh now they do
fantastic amount
and they're very inexpensive
so you can only afford these
Technologies uh
at a point where they don't really work
very well
you know once they get to be perfected
uh everybody can afford them and
literally everybody has these
smartphones yeah they're six billion
that's six billion I looked it's six
billion in the world out of eight
billion people that's that's crazy it's
a crazy number I checked on this like
nine months ago it's four billion
out of eight billion people
I mean I I walk down and I see homeless
people take out their cell phone and use
it right it's smartphone their
smartphone yeah so you can only afford
these things if you uh at a point where
they don't work once they're really
perfected everybody can afford them and
so that's going to be true of all of
these Technologies you don't have to be
wealthy I mean wealthy only allows you
access to a point where it doesn't
really affect anything
but that that presumes that we continue
to advance exponentially over that time
yes but that is the reality uh and do
you never see that ending
uh no I mean uh it's going to keep going
and what are you basing that on
part of it sounds like wishful thinking
I mean I'm with you but I'm just being
devil's advocate here uh who is to say
it should go on forever the Roman Empire
they surely thought they were a forever
thing Hitler was ready to be the third
Dynasty
he was ready to last at least as long as
the Greeks and the Romans and his
dynasty lasted 10 years so
uh where where's your is it just the I'm
queuing off of the past and projecting
into the future or do you have actually
knowledge of what will happen in the
future that will well I mean if we look
at the price performance of computation
it's gone on
uh there's actually some periods prior
to this before we had computation uh
that continues this graph into the past
uh and it's continued and people are
saying well I'm not sure it's going to
continue Moore's laws has ended every
five years people say Moore's law has
ended
whistle is not a good name for this
graph because only 10 of the 80 points
have to do but uh it's continued and
we plan things that that go beyond our
current limitations because we need uh
to overcome them
but I've read papers that said the
there's a you can't make the circuits
any smaller because you wanted to
Quantum effects uh I mean if you look at
nanotechnology for example
uh
there's an analysis if you created
the ultimate computer and it describes
exactly how that would work
uh uh in a one liter size
it would be billions of times greater
than than today's computers in fact it
would be greater than all the
computation of of all humans put
together
so we can go Way Beyond what's uh where
we are it will reach a limit
I mean there's the you're right there is
a limit but the limit's far beyond where
we are today and and we can actually
create a small computer that would be
greater than all human beings together
uh and and we can prove that uh as a
reality
so I hate to insult you by bringing this
up but just to take us out uh you I we
have to solicit your comment on whether
we're all living in a simulation
there but you're you know you're you're
dancing in the pond where people talk
about this so take us out with what you
think
is going on with us
I mean if if you look at how uh physics
works
it works by formula
and the world is kind of a computer
uh and so anything that happens in it is
kind of a simulation
uh of reality
the idea of us working in the simulation
is some high school students in some
other world create something basements
aliens basement juvenile aliens
programming us yes and they they create
something that simulates our world and
we're living in that world
um but it's still reality whether that
happens or not
and you'd want to actually encourage
those high school students not to shut
down
their simulation
so the way to do that is to be to be
interesting
and I think having a singularity would
be very interesting so they'd want to
watch that
uh very good good answer good good
answer okay so it's we want to keep our
simulator overlords entertains
all right Ray I think that's all the
time we have first a delight to chat
with you again uh good to see you're
still at it and that and you've got this
this new book coming out in 2023 I'll
look forward to that the the final print
version of it I feel privileged to have
seen an early manuscript of it I will
brag to others that I've seen an early
manuscript of it and it's the
singularity is nearer uh which is
clearly the case based on all the
evidence you bring to bear on that so uh
thank you Ray great to talk to you all
right all right you have been watching
and possibly listening to StarTalk Neil
deGrasse Tyson you're a personal
astrophysicist keep looking up
foreign
[Music]